a series of text messages that were
provided by Mark Meadows Donald Trump's
former Chief of Staff are absolutely
chilling in the complete and total
disregard for the Constitution and for
our elections that they expose
particularly from some Republican
members of Congress including one guy
Ralph Norman
who said that he wanted Donald Trump to
declare martial law that's
m-a-r-s-h-a-l-l which we'll get to this
is really horrifying stuff Republican
Congressman wanted Trump to invoke quote
martial law to stay in office based on
some leaked texts Mark Meadows texted
with 34 different lawmakers about
overturning the 2020 election including
a confused Ralph Norman talking points
memo has some of the most stunning
messages and at the top of that list is
this message we're putting up on the
screen from Ralph Norman who wrote to
Mark Meadows quote Mark in seeing what's
happening so quickly and reading about
the Dominion lawsuits attempting to stop
any meaningful investigation we are at a
point of no return in saving our
Republic Our Last Hope is invoking
martial law misspelled please urge
president to do so clearly
Norman a fan of the rapper Eminem whose
real name is Marshall Mathers and that's
what he meant by martial law he thought
some of the songs might be useful these
are not the actions of a small
government constitutionalist
conservative are they hey even though we
lost and the Constitution says Biden now
gets to be president let's try to invoke
and use the military to keep us in power
this was an attempt at a coup which he
said let's try and do it and importantly
this text message was sent on January 17
2021 think about what that means it
means that after seeing everything that
happened on January 6th Ralph Norman
thought give me some more of that stuff
we need more of that the Insurrection
I'd like to order another one please
bring me another one on the Rocks so
what is our takeaway and we'll post the
links there's a lot of other text
messages that you can look at for
example there's like a Jason Miller text
message FYI I asked Ali Pardo from our
press shop to get in touch with Mo
Brooks since he seems to be the ring
litter leader on January 6th they say
they will have as many as 50 members on
board on January 6th but we won't have a
list of names until Sunday or Monday
anyway the point here is they were all
planning they were all involved it's
it's even more horrifying than we
believed and I encourage you to look at
and read through the text messages but
what's the takeaway the takeaway is this
is not the last time they're going to
try this they're going to be back there
was way more support for this than we
might have thought or hoped number one
number two the recent Marjorie Taylor
green clip that we looked at yesterday
where she said you know if I had been in
charge of the Insurrection I would have
been armed and we would have won means
that they see what happened on January
6th as a loss not because there were
crimes committed not because people got
arrested they see January 6th as a loss
because they didn't succeed in stealing
the election
and getting the guy who didn't win in
the Oval Office so they're clearly going
to try again they failed their execution
was horrible but it was clearly much
closer than it ever should have been to
being something that happened and could
have been their definition of success
there's no doubt what they wanted it's
not going to be the last time next time
the concern is will they have all of the
players in place
will they better know where it could be
hung up and be prepared to deal with
that will they have strong recover from
courts after more V Harper will they
have a legal framework to ignore
elections so this is a red alert moment
one of the things I always try to do on
this show is not to be hyperbolic uh and
and to catastrophize but this is really
worse than we've probably acknowledged
and we've acknowledged that it is pretty
damn bad so check out the text messages
we'll publish the links they're all
there and I'm sure by the way I haven't
looked through all of them it's
thousands of messages you may find
things that are as are even more
concerning than the martial law comment
from Ralph Norman let me know if you do
find those things
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
hold on bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below